after spending so long believing it was
just a myth
a hopeful wish of what could have been
for 2017's justice league
zack snyder's justice league is finally
out on hbo max
thanks to an extensive campaign from
fans warner brothers decided to make the
dream a reality
the four-hour long film premiered on the
streamer on march 18
2021 and reviews have been generally
positive
the film has a 73 percent on rotten
tomatoes with the critics consensus
declaring that zack snyder's justice
league lives up to its title
with a sprawling cut that expands to fit
the director's vision
and should satisfy the fans who willed
it into existence
compared to the 40 percent of 2017's
justice
league it's safe to say that zack
snyder's justice league is a success
along with better character development
a darker story
and intense visuals zack snyder's
justice league
has quite a few surprises and shining
moments of its sleep
one of these is the highly anticipated
appearance of jared leto's joker
first introduced in 2016 suicide squad a
poorly received film that just so
happens to also be getting a reboot of
sorts this year
while fans are definitely psyched for
letto's role in the new mega film
one question remains what does the actor
think about zack snyder's justice league
and
its version of the joker leto addressed
returning to the role of the joker in
his recent appearance on the late show
with stephen colbert while he was
promoting the little
things another hbo max film that earned
the actor a golden globe nomination
when asked about working on zack
snyder's justice league letto commented
i was just happy to be a part of his
dream and to get asked to play the joker
for a second time was just a treat
it's one of those rules that is just
incredible it's clear that leto admires
snyder and his vision
letta was not involved with the 2017
version of the film but snyder thought
to bring the joker back because
as he told the new york times this was
going to be the last movie i make for
the dcu and to have this entire
cinematic universe without batman
and joker meeting up just felt weird
snyder also kept it a secret from the
studio
he didn't even pay leto or ben affleck
for the scene which
is proof of letto's appreciation for the
director and his desire to be a part of
the project
in leto's interview with colbert the
actor reiterated this notion
saying i loved working with him i love
his passion he knows more about this
world and almost anybody when letto's
joker was first revealed as a part of
zack snyder's justice league in the
trailer the public went
wild and with good reason the joker
looks notably different in this film
than his previous appearance in suicide
squad
both physically and as a character
quoting headlines about zack snyder's
justice league that called the film
redemption for jared leto's joker
colbert asked boletto about the
difference between the joker and suicide
squad
and the version in snyder's hbo max film
leto didn't go into a lot of specifics
mainly citing the distinct
visions of different directors and how
they bring out different things in you
leto also related the experience to
colbert and his show saying that it's
like how
just like every guest you have it brings
out a different side or different joke
or a different
energy going further leto declared i
think it's an evolution
noting that the two versions are years
apart in the dc eu's timeline
it makes sense that the joker would
change a lot over that time
and it's possible that leto had more
involvement in the creative process of
developing his character this time
around
this is supported by the fact that the
line in the trailer that fans went crazy
for was actually ad-libbed by leto
leto noted the significance of zack
snyder's justice league beyond simply
allowing snyder to finish his film
he stated i always loved zack snyder and
i think that the story behind this
snyder cut is really kind of one for the
ages
of what happened to him kind of not
finishing the first film
he then went into an explanation about
the shirt he was wearing that read
we live in a society and it's meaning
this is a reference to leto's first
appearance in a trailer for hbo max's
zack snyder's justice league in which
his character says only that line of
dialogue which
led to a huge response from fans it's
later revealed that the full line is
actually
we live in a society where honor is a
distant memory isn't that right
batman leto took advantage of the craze
around this ad-libbed line and decided
to do something
meaningful with it he revealed that
shirts like the one he was wearing are
currently for sale on the official
website for his bend 30 seconds to mars
and all of the proceeds are going to the
american foundation for suicide
prevention
this cause holds a lot of meaning for
snyder and is a big part of why the
director was unable to finish the first
version of justice league
it's commendable that leto is doing this
to spread awareness and this only adds
another layer of meaning to an already
significant and monumental film
if you or anyone you know is having
suicidal thoughts
please call or chat online with the
national suicide prevention lifeline at
1-800-273-talk or 1-800-273-8255
text home to the crisis text line 741
741